we are so excited about season six of
mama june road to redemption where do
things pick up in the season premiere my
court case was resolved and then
uh juno does and then it goes from there
it
it talks about a lot of stuff that i
kept behind closed doors which is going
to be very hard because just watching
the first 10 minutes of the first look
um
it kind of like threw me back in that
hit space i was at a year ago which is
it's going to be hard to watch i'm not a
lot of you i'll probably cry i'll
probably
be very quiet because i'm gonna be
watching the show as you're gonna be
watching the show
i have to imagine that there's gonna be
a lot of really challenging moments this
season we've already seen a little you
know preview of those moments in the in
the super trailer there's a lot that i
have in mind closed doors that a lot of
people don't know you go back on
whatever you say it's not that easy
mama's bad choices are finally catching
up to her i'm scared i know what gina is
capable of what if something happened to
her where are you at with sobriety
uh almost 29 months straight sober oh
congratulations yes
29 months will be the 27th of this month
how committed are you to this new life
what are the things that you do to make
sure that you don't fall off the wagon
um
one you gotta have like you gotta wake
up every morning and tell yourself the
next 24 hours i don't give a [ __ ] if i
lose everything in my life i cannot go
back to that old lifestyle i met an
amazing person a little almost a year
ago now we were just friends
they came into my life when i was
friends he had no idea what was going on
in my life and
small little text messages of hey how
you doing just want to say hey have an
amazing day i was going through some
help learning who i was for the first
time you know people were coming in out
of my life and this person was just like
this is
my person and people were just like
going like this
and it was showing me like if you go
back to if you think about going back
into that addiction lifestyle this is
where you're going to be at and then
there was people that would show me hey
you can be treated like a queen and you
know stuff like that but then that one
person was just i mean sitting up here
to the right to the left of me but this
is you know
this person was right here the whole
time and i don't know and i started
really liking him and opened up the
chapter of our story september of last
year and
you know eight almost eight months ago
you know it's been a whirlwind so that's
justin sitting to the left of you i
assume yes yes and can justin just say
hi really quick i mean
well he can't get on the camera because
y'all got to wait on that baby
mama's home
what are you doing and she's back piling
on more drama
did mama call you and tell you what she
did at the airport just cut the [ __ ]
out of your life snips me out mama's
selfish ways are tearing us apart
a big thing on the show is is of course
your relationships with your girls let's
start with pumpkin how is your
relationship with pumpkin today
um it's good like we see each other we
just saw her like last week everybody
lives in that same right there so it's
like we see everybody it's not just like
oh we just see one and don't see the
other it's not like them
okay you know it's it's hard for me to
watch some of those scenes between you
and pumpkin because she's really had to
step up and she's had to not only be a
mom to her little ones she's now kind of
mothering alana and even jessica um do
you ever feel
guilty about the way things that have
about that you know
people you know you know i do feel like
a guilt because like i left them i chose
an addiction but if you've never had an
addiction you don't understand
how that feeling is because you just
want to be numb but
you know justin has taught me not to
become a runner and feel the emotions
and i'm not gonna lie to you
it kills me sometimes i feel the
emotions that i wasn't feeling in my
addiction
but then it feels good to kind of be
grounded for once in my life a big thing
that i see your girls you know not just
pumpkin but also alana they say a lot is
you know mama always says
she wants to be a part of our lives and
she wants to be present but her actions
sort of indicate otherwise so what is it
that you're doing to show them
actions well we moved back me and justin
moved back to georgia uh we live with
probably like 15 minutes away from the
girls
um being able to like reach out to them
more be able to be more present like
seeing them more
hanging out more you know because like
you know when i went into recovery you
know i stayed in south florida for like
two years in my
addiction i was selfish but i'm even
more selfish in my recovery because i
have to take care of me at the end of
the day and i take care of me to be good
for anybody else even myself just be
good for my own self so that is the
reason why i chose to work on me
you know what i'm saying
until so i can be my better version for
myself for my children for justin for
everybody involved for the first time in
42 years i've experienced unhappiness
loving myself knowing that i'm worth it
and it took 42 years to get to this
point how are things with you and alana
right now
um a lot of the relationship is going
good um you know you see that throughout
the season you know she is turning 17 in
august you know so that's the thing you
know she is you know she's graduating
next year a lot of people still look at
her that six-year-old little girl but
she's making me 17. so
um
it's kind of crazy
we see in the super trailer that you and
pumpkin go to you go to a little bit of
a battle there over who is gonna take
over raising alana alana can stay here
i'm her mama now
you alana is mine and i can take her
back any time i want she can't do that
can she take her ass to court tell me
about those emotions i mean did you feel
like you were in a place where alana
could come back to live with you and
always you know our door has always been
open you know justin has been you know
around the kids and you know they know
you know that all of our kids are
welcome because you know he's got kids
himself so any all the kids are welcome
you know there's six in between both of
us and their our door is always open
um no matter how old they get or where
they're at in life if you had it your
way would alana come back and live with
you
um yeah i would i would um but you know
people don't understand that she's an
added age that she's able to make her
own choices and i know they say that oh
she's 16 she can't make her own choices
well in a lot of stays the age of 16 you
can make your choices
and it seems like she's really in a
great space living with pumpkin in the
new house i see her doing her homework i
see that she
seems to be
doing well under pumpkin's roof i mean
how does that make you feel you know i
mean i've never said anything bad a
pumpkin i'm grateful for pumpkin taking
over when i couldn't take over it i'm
very grateful in that faith i've told
pumpkin that a hundred times you know um
but you know like i said i mean it's not
like i feel some kind of way like you
know what i'm saying like people don't
understand there's a lot that transpires
behind closed doors that we've left
behind closed doors
but you know like i tell people all the
time you know alana is old enough that
she can make her own decisions and that
you know if a long court battle happens
then you know she at the ultimate end of
the day she gets to make her own choices
where she wants to live i know that
we're going to see little teases of
alana being in a relationship one thing
i ask is respect and the truth are
really really good and if you don't i'm
just going to break your neck have you
met her boyfriend what do you think yeah
i've met dryland yes and they've been
together over a year um he's good um you
know he needs to hold down a job a
little bit more but hey that's typical
teenager also what does he do um right
now he just um helps out a friend of
ours and works a little bit with josh
they're teenagers she's 16. if they last
fine if they don't it can be your first
love
you look fantastic where are you
in your health journey physically i
could be losing a few pounds or two or
five or 20 or 30 or 40 50
healthy weight
um
but you know mentally i'm in a good spot
right now in my life i'm mostly i'm in a
good spot still dealing with stuff every
once in a while um
but physically yeah i mean i could
probably lose 50 or 60 pounds but hey
i'm happy where i'm at i kind of think
this 240 way
is where i need to be at because i've
been that way for about a year and a
half now you use the word transformation
and you're in such a different place
than you once were right
what are three goals that you have for
yourself whether personally or
professionally that you'd love to
achieve in this like next era of mama
june
um for me as this one just to be happy
um
two you know to
help as many people as i can through my
own life experiences and that's why i
continue to share our story unscripted
and wrong
um
also you know to be able to work on my
relationships whether it be myself it'd
be justin it'd be the kids
um so i'd have to say like that's
probably my top priorities and at the
end of the day justin says what do you
say
peace some
peace of mind
peace of mind he always says that's your
main goal is you need to be a peace of
mind because it's priceless
[Music]